my name is Gavin Heffernan and I'm a
filmmaker with Sunchaser pictures calm
and this time-lapse was made as part of
sky glow project calm which is a big
initiative that my partner rune and I
have launched towards reducing light
pollution and studying its impacts on
cities as well as visiting some of the
most incredible dark sky preserves in
North America I fell in love with the
Stars when I was a kid growing up in
rural Bosnia and one of the rituals if
you will that we used to do is get
around the campfire every night and talk
about different subjects and stars were
almost almost always the most important
one what we found is when you're
shooting this stuff at 25 to 30 second
exposures on your camera it's it's
letting in so much light that even if a
city is a hundred miles in the distance
it can blow out the stars and they can
take away the Milky Way and and all
those things that were out there trying
to account to capture what we wanted to
accomplish with this time-lapse was to
sort of ask people what if and to show
them essentially what it could be like
if we made some smart choices and made
some of the adjustments necessary to
actually protect the night sky even over
some of the most life limited places in
the world
we composited some of the really darkest
night sky stuff that you find from areas
like Grand Canyon and other parts like
Death Valley over the city shots and
gave that effect that you see there I
think the moment one starts
photographing the night sky you are by
default an activist you're showing
something that's so rare and then it
exists in a pristine form in so few
places and I think when you put it in
a form of motion it allows people to
have a kind of an experience you
experiencing what ancestors used to
experience but a much sort of faster
rate he grounds you I think in so many
ways and that's the beauty of time-lapse
I mean the point is to capture things
that the eyes can't see